well aside from schools you know
businesses
uh really had to stick together through
the pandemic and
every neighborhood seems to have its own
local haunt you probably have yours too
wherever it is
and and that's no different for an area
just north of here in sunrise
manor on far east charleston it's called
sunrise casablanca
and it's got generations of east siders
who have supported that bar
and vice versa during the pandemic
shutdown now
a young couple who runs the restaurant
inside casablanca sunrise casablanca
they found out what being neighbors good
neighbors
truly means i find the people on the
east side
to be much like the people in the
midwest they're very accepting
and when you're in you're in mike
sullivan's family has owned sunrise
casablanca for 25 years
expanding from its humble beginnings as
an east side watering hole back in the
1950s
las vegas up here stick together through
good times and
bad and the pandemic was one of the
worst we were completely shut down
we did didn't have any revenue for for
three months
it was a devastating blow for the young
cooking couple who leased casablanca's
kitchen
ryan whelan and kelsey alder were just a
year into their new restaurant catering
and food truck business
monty's smokehouse barbecue business was
sizzling when the phone calls and emails
started
cancelled canceled refund cancelled
cancel
yeah every dollar they had was tied up
in their cooking ventures
our business partner told us dry your
tears
pull your pants up and figure it out and
that's just what they did
devising a plan to help feed
neighborhood locals
and keep their staff working they
reached out on a community facebook page
east siders taking action offering
weekly menus of affordable cooked meals
think comfort food blue plate special
type stuff
spaghetti and meatballs beef stroganoff
fish and chip dinners
the meals were a delicious hit and word
spread like a kitchen grease fire
through sunrise manor we had over 100
orders the very first day
and it didn't slow down there mike
didn't cook but he helped where he could
he said don't worry about your rent
don't worry about us
we are here we're doing this together
let's get through this
yeah i was happy to do it
just they're just wonderful people they
give so much and
don't expect anything in return for
nearly three months cars lined up around
the block for the daily specials
customers often paid extra to make sure
neighbors who weren't working
were able to eat it was heartwarming
the response was excellent everybody was
so very grateful i never would have
thought
this type of community would have
existed on this side of town i don't
know why
i just it's a whole other world it's a
country town out here is what it is
and it's way more old vegas feel and
neighbors are neighbors
well you know that went on for about
four months or they were feeding people
and sunrise casablanca was closed that
whole time
and boy montes was rent free they said
that's the only way that they would have
survived so
kudos to mike and boy they are real
partners in that business there on
on east charleston they're about to open
a wing business and go in partnership
with green valley grocery if you'd like
to check out their wing business
so they'll be up and running there
that's where their food truck has been
parked
lately but they're going to be inside
cooking in the kitchen so
they got a lot of catering gigs going on
again so business is
back and booming and they haven't had a
day off since february
and they need to hire a couple of
employees too at least two so if you
need a job
and you're a good cook call them they'll
hire you john
alex i just want to go there and eat
sherry that looks so good
tasty oh the food was so good yeah
sherry thanks for giving us this tour of
sunrise banner i know it's great for you
to explore hopefully
you had a good time meeting some of the
good folks out there in that east part
of town
great job out there sherry thank you
appreciate that